let's talk about third parties in the
united states and i put the word third
in quotation marks because there's more
than one third party so you could even
think of it as a third fourth fifth
sixth and seventh parties but the reason
why people say third parties is because
in the united states you have two
dominant parties you have the
republicans and you have the democrats
and so any other party is considered to
be a third party after those first two
big dominant parties
so here are some of the logos of some of
the i would say major third parties in
the united states and i'm going to put
major in quotes because they don't have
much of a say in our government today
you have the libertarian party
that is very focused on people's
individual liberties they generally
think about the government doing as
little as possible that whenever the
government tries to get bigger it
infringes on people's liberties either
in the economic sphere or in the social
sphere
the green party is also very pro-civil
liberties but you can also imagine
because it's called the green party it
is very concerned with the environment
now this third third party and there's
many more than just these three this is
the reform party and the reform party is
really interesting because it was
started by ross perot in 1995.
and this was after in 1992 ross perot
ran as an independent candidate for
president and he did surprisingly well
he got nearly 20 percent of the popular
vote
but an interesting question is even
though he got 20 of the popular vote in
1992 and even though in the reform party
had some reasonable support even in the
1996 election how come we don't see
congress people who represent the reform
party and there's two real answers here
one is the winner-take-all system
winner take
all
so if we're dealing with a situation
where even if a third party gets 20 of
the vote they're not going to get any
representation for it and you can
contrast that with a proportional
representation system like you have in
some parliaments so in some countries
their parliament is elected by
proportional representation so let's say
that 20 percent vote for party
a
let's say
70 percent vote for
party
b
and then the remainder 10 vote for
party
c
in a parliamentary proportional
representation system party c would get
roughly 10 of the seats in the
parliament but that's not the way it
works in our government in our
government in almost any jurisdiction if
you had a voter breakdown like this well
party b would win or maybe sometimes
party a would win and even if party c
does get some votes it's never going to
cross the threshold to actually get
representation now with that said this
doesn't fully explain why we don't see
more third party representation in say
the united states congress because there
are countries that have more third party
representation even though they don't
have proportional representation now
another reason that's often cited for
why we don't see third party
representation is that the major parties
the republicans and democrats oftentimes
incorporate the third party's messages
into their own
to get a sense of this i'm going to show
you a little bit of an excerpt from a
reform party ad in 1996. and at that
time they were saying things that
neither the democrats or the republicans
were saying very strongly and i want you
to think about when you hear it whether
some of those messages have later on
become part of either the republican or
the democratic candidates messages
washington is selling our future to the
special interests don't waste your vote
on someone who will sell you out ross
perot is the only candidate who will
work for our interest instead of the
special interest just vote for ross
because you own this country
so as you saw in that ad from the reform
party there's a lot of talk about the
influence of special interest and how
people need to take their government
back and if you fast forward to the 2016
presidential election you had two major
forces actually one on the republican
side and one on the democratic side on
the republican side you have donald
trump who's echoing the need to focus on
special interest that washington is a
swamp and it needs to be drained it
wasn't obvious from that ad but ross bro
in 1992 was ringing the alarm bells
about nafta and free trade and saying
why it would be bad for the united
states and in 2016 you heard many of
these same things from the republican
candidate donald trump same thing with
bernie sanders on the democratic side he
echoed the need to take a second look at
free trade and that special interests
had taken over washington